thank you guys we have hikaru nakamura
on tap hikaru you haven't played in a
couple of years actual actual board play
pieces in front of you in a tournament i
don't know what you've done for fun but
certainly in a tournament how did it
feel to be back at a board and
especially here in st louis i mean it
didn't seem much different from two
years ago so
you know i think a lot of people have
made a lot about how online or over the
board are different but you know i think
if you see what magnus has done or what
wesley's done it's i mean it's still the
same game at the end of the day and um
you know maybe in the first time i was a
little bit too slow at some critical
moments but overall i thought i
calculated well and um and then
obviously in the third game today i you
know took advantage of peter's slight
mistake when he traded his knight for
the bishop on d2 and it all worked out
so
uh yeah
to be expected i guess
uh you're a wild card here which is not
frequent for you normally you're a tor
participant what's your motivation in
this event are you thinking crush crush
kale kill
um well i mean first of all i consider
myself a streamer more than a pro player
at the moment so when you say being a
wild card versus being a um being a full
tour participant that really i mean it
makes no difference to me um
but you know i think uh what i would say
is that perhaps in a situation if um
if i was you know perhaps
let's just say serious about this event
or expecting to win i would maybe have
made a repetition earlier in the game
earlier in the game because i thought i
was perhaps
maybe a little bit worse if i continued
on but there's really nothing to lose
for me i'm just you know i'm playing
with house money so it's all good
playing with house money sounds
dangerous to the rest of the field who's
trying to get some points
will you be streaming after this is over
like when you leave this interview yeah
you know i think when i won the u.s
championship in 2019 i actually did some
sort of recap of every game and i ended
up winning the event so it was really
good but during this event not really i
think uh
i'll try to prepare relax and um you
know i am focused on the event i want to
want to do as well as i can but
certainly the start that i had today was
really important with the two blacks
getting those two draws and then winning
this nice game against peter so i mean
to me
you know it's hard it's hard to know
what to expect after not playing but i
feel like it's it's a it's
what i would have hoped for
all right well we hope for like if i can
get a question in because i was just
really amazed to carry on that first
game
at what point were you out of theory how
did you calculate your way out of it
what was your thought process around the
moves queen b7 a little bit before that
well you know i i actually have to say
that after the game i had a feeling this
was going to be a good day specifically
because when i used those like i think i
thought for maybe 15 minutes or
something crazy trying to do a do a gary
um where i just you know think forever
and don't move but the reason the reason
that i had a feeling to be a good day is
because specifically in that position
when i when i calculated this whole line
with um queen b7 you just keep going to
knight f8 94 yeah
this position what happened in the game
takes queen e4 f3 i actually during that
time i calculated this line with queen
e3
uh this queen e3 with bishop d8 knight
f4 queen eight king h7 rook f2 let us
catch up sure d8 knight f4 yeah queen
eight
queen e8 oh yeah king h7 yeah yeah rook
f2
okay knight h3
right rook f1 yeah knight of four
oh my god d2 yeah knight g2
yeah king d1 yeah
queen b3 oh my gosh yeah king c1
queen a2 and and so during this time
when i thought for the 15 minutes i was
calculating this and i thought this was
probably okay but again you know by the
time i decided i only had about four and
a half minutes left and
again i'd follow a position where i'm
down a rook and if i'm fully precise i
can probably draw it and um and so like
the point that i was about to say is
that after the game i actually asked
shakur and he said that queen f4 was to
surprise him and he had he this whole
line with queen e3 queen b3 queen a2 was
a draw and that gave me a really good
feeling because when i used all that
time and i calculated something that was
the top computer line i knew that i that
i was on and then secondly as far as the
theory goes um i was out of theory
probably around the time i played bishop
g2 and rook g1 the order was a little
bit unusual for me and and so that was
that of course later maybe i had a
chance to to win the game perhaps but i
was a little bit low on time first came
back you know very up and down it didn't
didn't seem like the moment to take some
huge risk and um it's it's very good so
i'm very very pleased
well i i was calling you a freak a freak
of nature the ability to come back and
and
just play any kind of chess anytime you
want they told me i should actually call
you a beast so i'm gonna stick to that
but
that that kind of calculation is
absolutely freakish and beasty at the
same time yeah but i mean i i think what
i would say though is there i mean
there's also a third example you know
magnus and wesley obviously have played
really well but even vishy who didn't
play almost at all online during the
past years he played in croatia and did
really really well finished in second
place so i think it's it's sort of just
staying active and looking at chess
that's most important i mean they've
done it so why can't i indeed well let's
see some more of that good play good
luck in the rest of your games thank you
mike i'd just like to say uh also uh
hikaru that on behalf of ourselves
uh this game that you had with shaq was
just fantastic it was really really
really remarkable and as marie said if i
if you played that in classical chess uh
you would be proud of yourself well done
just really great stuff thank you thank
you absolutely absolutely beautiful
chess that we've seen today